i just spoke with a 13 year old last  week who said that she was confused  for an entire year of what her gender  was because in school her teachers the  millennials that were  these useful idiots i'll call them that  that  don't even understand what they're  talking about half the time to the kids  these millennial teachers are pushing  the the pride flags in schools they have  groups that you're allowed to join these  lgbtq whatever groups and  and you're not allowed to join any other  groups you should prob they encourage  people to join these groups that and  then it's just so it's surrounded  it's they're constantly surrounded by it  and then they get confused and then it's  a cool thing for their friends to do and  it becomes a fad she was confused for a  year because it was in her environment